like many of the best professional
photographers flo ngala finds herself at
the intersection of art
and photojournalism over the last few
years a 26 year old photographed some of
the world's most iconic celebrities
but when americans took to the streets
in the wake of george floyd's murder
and gala was inspired to capture those
scenes those
images taken in her hometown of new york
city draw from the street photography
and portraits
that stretch back to the start of her
career
on my way to school i would have my
camera with me literally these streets
like anyone who looked beautiful
growing up in her harlem neighborhood
flo and gala quickly discovered the
beauty
all around her and more than a decade
ago began
documenting it with her camera how old
were you when you were taking these you
think
i was like 15. and gala met us at a
neighborhood pub
it was once home to a store run by her
parents
who immigrated from west africa in 1992.
they owned a hair rating and beauty
supply store it was very much a family
business
like the first exposure i had to a black
owned business which was very powerful
it was really like an immigrant story of
like just
hard work and perseverance harlem is
like this beautiful mecca of black
excellence
seeing that and being inspired by that
is what was ingrained in me
at a very very young age they were just
fearless and resilient so that's where i
got that from
her parents along with a high school
photography teacher encouraged her to
get creative
we got really close and i think that
created a very safe space for me to
create
she also was a very like sharp woman and
that's kind of how i learned i think for
sure just like the tough love of it
my dad passed away in 2008 and so he
actually never saw me become a
photographer but i do feel like
my entry into photography happened very
soon after his passing
i remember i was always attracted to
people who were deep in thought
seeing things like on the subway you
know that's the actual best place to see
all parts of new york city
she began with self-portraits and street
photography
then in college she was cast as an extra
in a fat joe music video
it wasn't her work on screen but behind
the camera that
led to her big break i emailed the
photos to the director and the producer
he sent those photos to someone that he
works with at atlantic records
a marketing executive at the record
company liked what she saw
and offered her an opportunity to
photograph rapper gucci mane after he
left prison in 2016.
the following year she captured cardi
b's assent to fame and gala
was only 22. i always really believed in
myself and ultimately that's what i
think
has manifested itself into exactly what
i thought i wanted to do
at 15. she has since photographed
various celebrities from rapper busta
rhymes to actress leticia wright
and politician stacey abrams and landed
covers on billboard
and the new york times and gala's main
mission behind the camera she says
is to tell the truth with somebody like
cardi b
what do you see i still see her as a
woman of color from the bronx
who like got out the mud like that's
exactly how i see her
and i know exactly what that feels like
and looks like because i did it
my mom did it and so there's no kind of
i think
narrative i'm imposing on her when
demonstrations swept new york a little
more than a year ago following george
floyd's death
and gala took to the streets first to
protest
then to photograph he was murdered the
same week as my 25th birthday i just was
like well there's
no way i can just sit here and if it
wasn't for photography there were so
many things that we would have never
been able to see and those things were
the truth that's how things were at the
time that's how people felt them to be
so i think that's what really felt
powerful to me
and gala is also an alumni of the
organization figure skating in harlem
which you will recall we featured right
here on cbs this morning back in march
wow yeah she told me that it's a
blessing to be an alumna
and that sisterhood and the community of
the program fostered
her own personal development she started
she do
honestly she's a figure skater fantastic
i love the shot you just showed the
black and white with the hand raised and
this
guy with the mask really strong
photography and her personality
she looks i mean that's one of the
things we talked about when she's
photographing
she searches for the truth in the image
that she frames in her mind you know
what i like she captures moments
very candid that she just captures it
right when it's happening absolutely
she's also she's been she's had a couple
of opportunities and she's really seized
them that's really and she's only 26
years old
i just go ahead i was well i love that
it's her photography teacher from high
school that really encouraged
her and sent her on that props to that
photography teacher for
inspiring her and we talked a little bit
about those that came before her like
gordon parks who also
photographed really powerful scenes in
harlem um when he was a photographer for
life magazine
and she's inspired by that again another
example of a teacher that sees something
in you that you don't even see yourself
sometimes that's important
one teacher can change your life thank
you vlad